yıl 2017
sevgili eşimle beraber bir Yemekteyiz
bir akşam yemeğinde
insanlar birbirleriyle sohbet ediyorlar
işte Çocuklar nasıl
Havalar Bugünlerde iyi gidiyor mu
oyun hekime kullanacaksın gibi
muhabbetler yapılıyor
o sırada işte Sonra da bana geldi ya
Şerife sen ne yapıyorsun bu aralar ben
de böyle yeni yeni
öğretmenliğinden annemin zoruyla
seçtiğim öğretmenlik mesleğinden
inanılmaz derecede kaçacak bir yer
arıyorum yeni yeni yemeği keşfetmişim
yemek yapmaktan inanılmaz keyif alıyorum
Sanki zannedersiniz o güne kadar hiç
kimse yemek yapmamış ilk defa ben
yapıyorum ve en iyisini böyle ben
biliyorum ekşi maya keşfetmişim evde
ekmek yapıyorum Allah'ım sanki bir uzay
fiziği ve bana gördüğüme Her zamanki
gibi öğrenmekten ve öğretmekten çok
keyif aldığım için tuttuğumu yakalıyorum
hemen şey ediyorum ya bakıyorum bir ekşi
maya var diyorum ekmek yapılıyor diyorum
mayalıyoruz diyorum ekmeğini evde kendin
yapabiliyorsun diyorum
hemen başlıyorum yani çocuklardan o
hekimi kullanacağımdan bahsetmek yerine
o yemeğin böyle o fizik halini çözmüşüm
ondan uzay fiziği gibi ondan
bahsediyorum o sırada tam konuşmanın en
güzel yerlerinden Ben böyle paylaşmaya
tam açmışken kendime bütün
öğrendiklerimi karşılayaya aktarma
hevesindeyken
yavaşça bir el arkamdan belli mi
kavrayarak hayatım
öylesine sordular dedi
sevgili eşim Tabii ki biz bu arada her
akşam evde tek konuşmalarını birebir
olarak yapıyoruz bugün Karşımda
dinleyecek bir sürü insanım var ve benim
anlatacak çok konum var ve bu sene 2023
Oscar törenini alan ki huyum gibi
bak öylesine Sormadınız değil mi yani
benim bugün anlatacak çok şeyim var ve
anlatacak bir hikayem var umarım
öylesine sormamışsınızdır Ben
kırklı yaşlarımdayım 40 yaşındayım
sosyal medyada 47 olduğum yazıyor ama bu
durum benim çok hoşuma gidiyor Çok genç
gösterdiğini söylüyorlar
anamurluyum 9 yaşında bir oğlum var
kendi kendimde üretim yaptığım gıdım
kendim ürettiğim
kendi iç dünyamızdan beslenebildiğimiz
Sürdürülebilir şifalı Tabaklar
hazırladığım Arge Mutfağı geliştirdiğim
bütüncül bir şefim
anlatacağım hikayesi sonra
kulağa çok güzel geliyor sonralarında
bu böyle bir şeflik yıllarımda 30'lu
yaşlarımda dedim ki ya ben işte böyle
bir anne mesleğinde öğretmenlik seçtim
ve de hayatım boyunca hep şununla karşı
karşıya kaldım memur ailelerin çocukları
memur olarak doğar memur olarak
görüyorum ben bu prangadan kurtulmak
istedim ve istifa ettim Çok da hoş
karşılanmadı halde Ailesi öğretmen
olanlar memur olanlar bilirler 3 ay
falan ortalama konuşmadı Şimdi aramız
iyi bu TED konuşmasından sonra çok daha
iyi olacağını düşünüyorum artık
konuşmaya başlayacak benimle
mesleğimden istifa ettim ve o arada o
güne kadarki olan bütün birikimimle Yani
anneme karşı duracağım diye 7 yıllık
öğretmen hayatımda olabilir 7 yıl bana
göre bayağı uzun geçmiş 7 yıllık
öğretmenlik hayatımda bütün kazandığım
parayı dünyanın en iyi yemek
okullarından bir tanesinde İşte o
ekşimeye tam çözemediğim için ben bunun
okuluna gideyim dedim
bunu da öğrenmeye başladım Bütün paramı
ona yatırdım Tabii Serde Parayı oraya
yatırınca okulun 1 ayında hamile
olduğumu öğrendim ve biz olduğumda
birlikte Gittik Oradan beraber mezun
olduk oğlum şu anda 9 yaşında asla
arkasından o kadar parayı vermiş olmanın
yani telaffuz edemeyeceğim doların
arttığı bugünlerde bir girip
bakabilirsiniz
parayı o kadar verince Tabii okulda
birincilikle bitirdim hırs'tan bahsetti
ya demin Ömür çok tatlı bir şekilde hırs
güzel bir şey ama fazla iddialı olmamak
lazım
Okulu bitirdim okulu bitirdiğim yıllarda
tema Vakfında ve birçok gönüllü projede
tek evde çalışıyordum Çünkü bir öğretmen
ailenin çocuğu olunca o Serde her zaman
yardım iste İçinizde oluyor Ben ona şey
diyorum mavi bir mürekkep boyası gibi
düşünün O mürekkebi bir kere
damlattıkları zaman bir daha o gitmiyor
şu anda olduğu gibi ben öğretmenliği üye
istifa ettim bıraktım Ama hayatımın hiç
bir döneminde o öğrenmeyi ve öğretme
öğretme isteği gitmeyecek her zaman bana
sanki sormuşlar gibi yapacağım bir
anlatacak Hikayem olacak sonrasında TEMA
Vakfı dedi ki ya Şerife işte arazide
yaşıyorsun Böyle bir Çiftliğin var gelip
bir şeyler toprakla ilgili öğrenmek
ister misin Ben dedim ki ya ben bir
sıklemen bilirim Dedem anlatmıştı Bir de
Kardelen bilirim karı yarıyormuş öyle
bir çiçek var diye Ben dedim bir şey
bilmem tamam dediler biraz Toprak öğren
projenin başında dur dediler ki peki
dedim ne olacak ben sonunda bilmediğim
bir işe girmem önce çıkışını görmem
lazım girmem için dediler ki yani
dünyaca ünlü bahçıvan olacaksın dedim
tamam okey tamam çok güzel gözüküyor
inanılmaz bir etki Ee Nezahat diyor ki
Botanik Bahçesi Royal adamburg Botanik
Garden dünyanın en böyle konuşulduğu
zaman Instagram'da göreceksiniz diye
şaşırmayın dünyada da geçerli olan bir
bahçıvan oldum
oldum toprakla ilgili bir şey biliyor
musunuz Bir dosya açıldı arkasından 2016
yılında oğlum 1 yaşlarına falan geldi
dediler ki ya sen birincilikle bitirdin
böyle bir işte gitmemişler gör
restorancılık sektörü gör bu neymiş bir
öğrenci
ona gittim dünyanın en ünlü işte 3
mişler şeflerinin olduğu bir zemin
mutfakta 100 tane insanla birlikte 3
ayda çalıştım Bu arada 3 ay kaldım 12
kilo alıp geri döndüm tamamen bütün
beden ve yapım değişti o sırada da bu
aldığım Hani etrafı gezebildim
onları gezebildim fakat
o sırada gezip birazcık ortalığı
dolaşmış olsam da bir şeyler Bende
değişmeye başladı ve parmak kavramını
öğrendim Bir tasarım Sürdürülebilir
yaşant tasarımı 2016 yılında döndüm
hemen perma kültür tasarımcısı oldum
sonra yetmedi dedim ki ben toprağımı bir
onarayım etraftan duydum
onarım işte sürdürülebilirlik Bütün
bunlar dedim toprağımı onarayım Sonra
devam ettim
dediler ki bütüncül yönetim bütüncül
yönetim planlama bütüncül yönetim Finans
Çünkü sponsor Dipnot eşi bir yere kadar
tükendi bütün dünyanın
ters gidiyor finanse dağıldık elin Saver
bunlarda aldık ama ben bir aracı olayım
köklerimde arıcılık var işte meyvelerde
bir sorun var falan aracı oldum sonra
tıbbi şifalı bitkiler üzerine eğitimler
aldım bunları sertifikalarını aldım
bunların atölyelerini verdim onun
arkasından aldım hatta bunun tarımda
devam ettim Oradan da hala bitmedi
başladım astrolojiyi alma nedenim tarım
astroloji olmak istedim tarım
astrologluğu diye bir şey var ben de
öğrendiğimde çok şaşırmıştım Gerçekten
bu işin bir taramasyon tarafı var sonra
tarımda görsel sembolizm öğrencisiyim
hala Türkiye'de böyle bir Ekol var ve en
sonunda dayanamadım hala işler
çözülemedi ayur veda uzmanlığı aldım ve
da yaşam demek ayarı iyi demek iyi yaşam
eğitmeliyim Ben trainerin aynı anda
devam ediyor böyle bir her şey en son
Geldiğimiz noktada Şu anda da bugün o
eğitimde olmam gerekiyordu biliyor
dinamik tarım ne derseniz çok Afilli
biyodinamik Az önce çok güzel
gözüküyordu biyodinamik tarım ay
takvimine göre yapılan tarım demek şu
anda da onun son modülünü alıyorum 1923
yılında of diye bir antropolog bunu
öğrenmiş 8 tane ders vermiş 100
yıllarını kutlayacaklar Ben bilmem kaç
Euro'ya Kordon bile dedim itibarıyla
sayarsanız
maliyetini aldığım eğitimleri soyadı bir
maliyet olarak hesaplayın bütün yönetim
Finans konuları Bunlar geldiğim noktada
Yarın da gideceğim eğitime ondan
sonrakine gideceğim inşallah onu da
bitireceğim yani eğitimlerim böyle devam
ediyor Eğitim şart hala biteceğini
düşünmüyorum Peki bu arada ben
bir Gurme Şerife ile yaşam ALES Şerife
Şerife usulü Ben böyle yaptım şerifeci
yersen gibi bir şey oluyor sonrasında
Disney'de programlar yaptım 52 farklı
konuda 7 saatlik ortalama 350 saatlik
bir akademik yayın yapan geçmişim
öğretmeni olduğu için böyle atölyelerim
var yurt dışı atölyelerim var Ve bu
arada yarım milyon takipçisi olan bir
sosyal medyam var ve ben bir insülin
sırrım çok etkiliyim çok güzel influ
edebilirim
bir gün bir canlı yayında yine böyle çok
etkili olduğum bir can değil de
çiftçilerle konuşuyorum
yayında siyah fasulye hasadı yapmışım
çok gurur duyuyorum kendimle
çiftçiliğimle falan lafta söyletmiyorum
içerde var ya sonra siyah fasulye RASAT
ederken Çiftçi ile konuşurken canlı
yayın sırasında birden siyah fasulyenin
içinde böcekle uçmaya başladı ve bütün
siyah fasulyeler kurtlanmış bir içinde
böcek kaçmış yayında böyle ne yapacağımı
bir şaşırdım öğretmenlerin çok
kullandıkları eski bir özellik Ben de
tam size bu soruyu sormak için bunu
yaptığım gibi bir saklamaya çalıştım ama
olmadı yani orada o sosyal medyada O bir
türlü şey olmuyor Onu bir toparladım
yayını kapattım Bu arada da Kendime not
aldım hep şey var ya orada bir açık
belirtmeyelim öyle bir hep böyle bir
gizlediğimiz bir şey var Kendi içimizde
dedim ki Ya ben bunu tarım astroloji
Hocama sorayım biyodinamik tarımcılara
sorayım ne oldu da bu siyah böcek yani
siyah da julyeler
böceklerdi ben niye yanlış yaptığımı Bu
arada 10 yıllık bu dediklerimin hepsini
almış ama paraları dökmüşüm
teyze
Teyzem dedi ki Anneannem diyor ki dedi
Şerife'ye söyle
o Fasulyeleri siyah Fasulyeleri ayın
yenisinde hasat etmiş içinde Su var su
yürümüş O yüzden böcekler beslenebilmiş
bundan sonra tohumlarını saklamak
istediği zaman ayın eskisinde hasat
etsin ve tohumlarını bir sonraki yıllara
kadar saklayabilsin
Şimdi soruyorum Nasıl oluyor da anamurlu
esnemek kadın doksan bir yaşında benim
Saatlerdir size anlattığım onca para
döktüğümü Kendi kendine oluyor Dolar
hesabı yapınca üstüne bunu yaptım bu
kadar aldığım bir sürü etiketlendirdiğim
komandodandığım eğitimde henüz cevabını
bilemediğim bu Kadim bilgiyi bilip
telefonda bana söyleyebiliyor
şimdi Hazır mısınız ben size
anneannemi anlatayım Benim anneannem ona
Vur doğumlu yaşı 91 hala hayatta bugün
böyle giyinmemin nedeni Çünkü eskiden
ona giderken bir tane böyle bir kumaş
götürürdük o en sevdiği elbisesinin
diktirdi entarisinin benim için maviler
turuncular çok değerli Çünkü bir önceki
TED konuşmamda simsiyahmışım oğlum dedi
ki bugün annemin siyah beyaz lacivert bu
ne halt dedi böyle bir Ben de dedim ki
oğlum artık renklendik renklerin coşkusu
denen bir şey var çakralar var bu kadar
eğitim aldık Anneannem 91 yaşında hala
çok güzel bir yürümek kadınlarıyla
beraberdir mersinliler anamurlar ve
orada böyle rengarenkleri turuncular
şeyler Kınalı saçlar bugün onunla
birlikte bir bütünleşip bunları size
anlatmak istedim
Benim anneannem
hep Sabah ezanıyla birlikte kalkar sabah
ezanından azıcık önce kalkar ve güneş
doğmadan kalkar
köyde yaşıyor tabii ki kendi köyünde
yerde Sürdürülebilir bir çiftliği yok
benim gibi bir eko yerleşkesi yok yani
bahçesinde yaşıyor Anamur'un malaklar
köyünde meleklerden geliyor eski bir
ürün türü
ve çok erken saatte kalktığı için
namazını kılar dini müfredatının yerine
getirir ama benim anneannem Mesela benim
gibi Ayşegül Çoruhlu videolarını
izlememiş onun kitaplarını okumamış
sirke diyanetim bilmez Hani son dönemde
yapıyoruz ya diyanetleri Güneş saatinden
önce bir tek Allah rahmet eylesin
dedemin şu lafını bilir kıçına Güneş
görmeden kalkandan hayır gelir bilir
yani budur Bizim oralarda
inekleri vardı o zaman keçileri vardı
bilmiyorum işte bakabildiği kadar adamın
altındaki yerde ineklerde ısıtsın diye
Bu da benim perma kültürü bilgim para
hoşuna gitmemiş
sonrasında Anneannem kalkar ineklerini
Sağar kümesi açar hayvanları gündüzden
yemlemez buraya sonra geleceğim
gündüzden yemlemez onları dışarı
çıkartır Sonrasında o sağlığı sütü alır
eve İçeri girer mutfağında onu yoğurt
yapar tereyağı yapar Yoğurdun altından
kalanı Yayık ayranı yapar bizim bugün
öğrendiğim tarsuslularda yayık Neyi
ayran çomacı ayran sıkması ayran sıkması
gibi yapar onlarda kullanılır çökelek
yapar yani Sürdürülebilir Bir çiftlikte
kendi gıda aslında kendi Üretir ve de
böyle bir saat yavaş yavaş dedemin kahve
saatinden önce yani güneş kavlamadan ben
hamurlu olduğum için Adana'nın ve
Tarsus'un sıcağını çok iyi bilirim Güneş
kavlamadan yavrum 12.30'u olmadan önce
dedemin kahvesinin altına kahve altına
kahvaltısına saat 11.30'a tekabül eder
bize ya böyle bir ılık süt sıcacık
vardır tandır ekmeğini gider yüklüğünü
oradan alır koyar içine birazcık bal
ekler Ben inanıyorum ki Anneannenin
konfleksi Bu da ilk bulan insanlardan
biri Çünkü kaç sene öncesinden
bahsediyoruz Ben 40 olduğuma göre
sonrasında ya da o çökeleyi alır içine
bal koyar sıkmaya hazırlar verir yani
günün ilk öğününü yedirdi Şimdi
soruyorum Anneannem internetin
tersliğimi biliyordu Doktor zengin
börekçiyi mi dinliyordu ya da aralıklı
Oruç mu yapıyordu Hayır sadece şunu
yapıyordu kahve altında acıktığı zaman
bunu yapıyordu sonra
bunlar artık çok güçlü olmuştur
Siesta bugün aranızda hiç uykuyla ilgili
çalışanlar var bilmiyorum işte
Einstein'ın birçok Az uyku uyuyan
insanların başarılı insanların bu çarpı
dört kuralları var 11 ile iki arası
uyuduğun zaman çarpı 4 oluyor ama böyle
bir kestirme Siesta arası işte onu onlar
çok iyi yaparlar Çünkü güneşte tepede
olunca çalışmazlar arkasından kalkar Ee
işlerine devam eder bahçe işlerini yapar
Ekim dikim yapar bugün benim personel
trainer'ımla haftada 3 gün olarak
yaptığım müthiş squat hareketini ot
yolma şeklinde 45 dakika boyunca
yapabilen en ideal kadınlardan bir
tanesidir O yüzden 91 yaşında ve İncecik
ben haftada 3 gün personaldo Tarsus'ta
zor yapıyorum
sonrasında gelir çay saati olur
anneannemin Grande laptama tiyatro the
cat gibi bir seçimi yoktu Genellikle çay
saatinde iyi bir yaşam koçuyla da
çalışmadığı için sosyalleşirlerdi ve o
günün dedikodusunu yaparlardı dedikodu
yaparken de kahve çay falan olmadığı
için bizim bilir misiniz bilmem sarı
Adaçayı vardır sallama onu koyardı
yanına da kötü gör bisküvisini gördü
Pardon bisküvit onu yerdi ve de hiç de
böyle bir şeker problemi olmadı
anneannemin Hayatta hiç glutenle ilgili
bir problem olmadı laktoza karşı
alerjisi olmadı fonksiyonel beslenme ile
gidip geliyor Bir gün Detoks kamplarına
katılmadı
devam eder Anneannem Çayını da içer
sohbetini de yapar sosyalleşir iyi bir
yaşam koçuyla kendi dertlerinden alınır
ve akşamleyin hayvanları içeri sokar
hayvanlar içleri sokarken yem verir
kaynak gösteriyorum şu anda eğitimini
aldığım bilmem kaç euro olan eğitimde
Dün öğrendik hayvanları Akşamları tek
öğün beslediğiniz zaman tüm canlılar az
beslendiği zaman uzun yaşar özellikle
güneş batmadan önce bu bilgi çok yeni
ilk defa size verdim Yarın Instagram'da
Yıldız yapacağım ona göre ama Anneannem
bunu yıllar
öncesinde Yemeğini de güneşten önce
İşte o zaman da bahçeye çıkıyordu
diyordu ki ya benim bahçede ne var ne
yetişiyor mevsimsel düşün yerel beslen
Mesela biz bunu markadan şu bana bir
eşim var onunla oturduk bulmaya
çalıştıklarını aldık Anneannem 91
yaşında kadınlar zaten bugün desem ki
anneanne mevsimsel düşün yerel Besler e
Çocuğun başka ne edeceğini diyecek zaten
Yani ne varsa onu yiyoruz Dolayısıyla
onları yer akşam ezanından sonra da
böyle bir güneş battıktan sonra
hayvanlarla beraber uyur
ve duruyorum
bu Esme kadın bunca yılın sonunda benim
bu kadar aldığım eğitimlerde Neyi
benimle birlikte aynı yapıyordu da ben
bu kadar yılın sonunda bunu öğrenemedim
şurada notlarımın devamını bulayım
[Müzik]
sonrasında Ben şunu fark ettim Benim
anneannem yani eşime Kadın kendi
dualarında kendi yaşamında kendi
dünyasında bugüne kadar annesinden
dedesinden ninesinden öğrendiği Kadim
bilgileri hiç sorgulamadan yerine
getirdi ve hiç bir Trend kirlilik
yaşamadı O yüzden en iyi bildiği şey
kadimdi ve onu gerçekleştirdi şimdi
Ben Son aldığım bir eğitimde gerçekten
çok önemli bilgi öğrendim bu arada bütün
aldığım eğitimleri bir yana Gerçekten
benim için çok değerli Çünkü bugün
kadimin yorumlayabiliyorsam Aslında bu
gücün sayesinde yorumluyorum
ve şunu fark ettim şimdi sıkı durun
Toprak mikrobiyolojisi belki
duymuşsunuzdur mikrobiyota illain ingun
çok değerli bir kadındır gerçekten en
önemli eğitimlerden biridir son dönemde
bileğinin bir dersinde şunu duyduk
ineğin dedi ki ben bugüne kadar hep
Toprak üstü yüzeyle olan sorunlarla
uğraştım Ben de öyle hep böyle bir
hastalık oldu gittim aracı oldum bir
hastalık oldu agrome empati öğrenmeye
çalıştım bir şeyi bilemedim tarım onları
indi bir şey bilemedim üçüncüyü yönetim
alayım dedim hep eğitimleri aldım ama
sonra fark ettim ki gerçek problem
insanın kendi
toprağının niteliğini arttırdığı zaman
ortadan kaybolabiliyor Benim anneannem
bu işi farkında olmadan Bugün ben ona
anlattığım zaman çok doğru bir şekilde
yapıyordu yani
toprağının niteliği ne kadar iyiyse
Toprak ne kadar nitelikli ise berekete
de o kadar bol oluyordu O yüzden bugün
teorim astrolojisinde ve astrolojide
öğrendiğim ve çok keyif aldığım bir şey
söyleyeyim size notları bırakalım artık
rahatladık insanın bedeni kendi
toprağıdır
element dersi Toprak
insanın bedeni kendi toprağıysa
günü nasıl başladığınız ne yediğiniz
ne ile kendinizi beslediğiniz
nasıl bir insan olduğunuzu nasıl bir
katkı sağlayacağınızı belirler
o yüzden
Tüm bu seçimleri yaparken istediğiniz
kadar renklenin istediğiniz kadar en
güzel gıdaları yiyin En bereketli
hazineniz bedeniniz Yani toprağınız
benim esmek adından bugüne kadar
öğrendiğim bilgi bu toprağınızın
Bereketi bol olsun
[Alkış]